this is a large Convoy headed
with police motorcycle outriders oh you
know the police have got to clear the
streets around the court complex because
there has been a sort of do-it-yourself
pro-trump procession and motorcycles and
large trucks going on all day so they've
got to clear those streets they've got
to get them off the road so they can get
Trump out of here we expect that he will
be going
North to his Golf Club in New Jersey
Bedminster it's expected to give public
remarks there he may stop however for a
meal in Miami we're not sure that is a
possibility
they seem ready to go big Security
operation
for the U.S Secret Service some concerns
from U.S officials here
about the way the Miami Police have
decided to do this you've had pro-trump
supporters
and you've had anti-trump supporters
mingling with with high-profile members
of the American Media all in the same
space here we go
[Music]
people's starting to churn Trump for USA
seen all sorts of different Maga
supporters
that is what love looks like people
heard there
we go huge huge raw of approval from the
crowd here
it's a large Convoy moving slowly
you don't know which vehicle Trump is in
but it's celebratory isn't it
doesn't look like a man he's just been
charged with 37 Federal Criminal counts
we love Trump people say USA they see
him the rightful leader of the United
States
[Applause]
[Music]
armed officers in some of these vehicles
for rushing towards one
one of the vehicles it may have slowed
down given them away
chaotic things
police really outnumbered here doing
their best
people running after one of the vehicle
one of the vehicles
again not the not the scenes that you
would associate with someone
who's just had to plead not guilty
the 37 Federal Criminal Council